(labored breathing)
- Your son?
- That was fast work.
- You're scaring him.
Just promise you won't hurt him.
- What the hell did you
get up to last night?
(techno music)
♪ The party's swinging
in like a wrecking ball
♪ People getting naked
for no reason at all
♪ Guts puking up and
tongues down throats
♪ Uncle Lenny's telling
all his racist jokes
♪ After the after-after party
♪ Went for some alone time
♪ you know me on my own time
♪ Are you gonna make me say this
♪ I had to touch myself up good
♪ Don't wanna let this night die
♪ So I have a half a pork pie
♪ Now I'm back out to the party
♪ So we can set
this thing off right
♪ Do you understand
what I'm sayin to you
♪ No, not really
♪ Wait, I think I do
♪ That little thing
was born in your bin
♪ So he's part pork
pie and a part of you
♪ My boy, my boy, meet my boy
♪ Gonna be the best
dang dad you ever had
♪ Even if your mum
was a meat based snack
♪ My boy, my boy, meet my boy
♪ They can't say it's a sin
♪ even though I let
you gestate in my bin
Hey son, I'm just
calling to let you know
I'll always love you as a
father figure and as a friend.
♪ So did you fuck the pork pie
♪ No, I did not
fuck the pork pie
♪ But, how does that even happen
♪ It doesn't matter now, move on
♪ People say you
look just like me
♪ Like me
♪ Well, crossed
with Keira Knightley
♪ Knightley
♪ Wanna capture every moment
♪ Like when you say
your first words
- Kill me.
♪ My boy, my boy, meet my boy
♪ Play sports, but
you're not that tall
♪ The other kids'll try
and use you as the ball
♪ My boy, my boy, meet my boy
♪ You don't look
like the other kids
♪ Cause they're not
made out of pork and jiz
♪ My boy, my boy, meet my boy
(screaming)
(panting, banging and
liquid splattering)
- Stef, I can't believe you
sacrificed your own son for me.
(drops bat)
- I don't think I'm
ready to be a dad.
- Hey, you'll be a great
dad when you're ready.
- Yeah,
I guess everything
worked okay in the end.
- What the fuck's that?
Guys, guys, what the
fuck's that on my back?
(laughing)
- Oh, fuck off.
Why you laughing?
A fucken face on my back.
What am I su--
Who the fuck's Senior Cool Guy?
You know tattoos
are permanent right?
(techno music)
- This gonna be the
best tattoo ever.
♪ The party's swingin
in like a wrecking ball
♪ People getting naked
for no reason as all
♪ Guts puking up
and tongues down